kannst du mal so ein video machen so
einen tag als cutter von baby also was
zusammenpasst
[Musik]
guten morgen so ich bin jetzt im ufer
angekommen habe gerade schon
gefrühstückt und jetzt ist es 9 uhr 30
das heißt jetzt will das war ein video
geschnitten
[Musik]
so leute kleine planänderungen denn
warum es gerade flotte meinen warum
planen und weil ich anscheinend nichts
geschrieben habe dass wir vom einzelnen
sportlichen hab mich aber verschrieben
ich wollte eigentlich schreiben um 11
uhr dann kann ich jetzt ganz ganz
schnell fertig und dann geht es auch dem
sport sowie die ränder sind jetzt fertig
ich wollte jetzt eigentlich in ruhe hier
mein mega kraska das essen essen grüße
gehen daraus eine köchin an dieser
stelle der muss mit diesen wunderschönen
moment was auch super weil ich jetzt
klingen muss damit das ist auf jeden
fall reisekomfort stabilität
da sind wir auch schon fertige sport
fleißig wie eh und je besser zu hause
die schnauze voll erhalten genau und
dann sehen wir uns heute abend wieder
nach wo ich bin jetzt wieder in ufa und
habe noch einiges vor und zwar sieht man
das vielleicht hier habe ich heute schon
videos steht dessen mit tier ein
bisschen was gelesen hab den blog hier
geplant ja ich musste so etwas planen so
traurig es klingt ab dann blog einträge
macht habt dann dieses schicken game
geschnitten wollen die danone hat leon
bisschen alles durcheinander gebracht
dann waren wir beim sport ich bin
relativ guten zahlen sagen eigentlich
würde gere 14 uhr 30 das nächste regel
wieder anstehen aber gar nicht so guten
zeitraum bin kann ich damit in 20
minuten früher wegen arger vorher werde
ich erst mal die erste frage wären würde
ich habe auf instagram wieder dazu
aufgerufen fragen zu stellen und zwar
die erste frage lautet machst du auch
mal gaming einfach mal das video kommt
morgens pixel was macht man also aus
sieht dein alltag gut so denn wirklich
dass er schon draußen kann man das
zeigen das originale alltag hier und da
wir heute nicht hier ist sieht man auch
nicht wie ich die falschen gepeinigt
werden bestimmt und vor allem ist es 80
dezibel leiser die frage was machst du
auch mal gaming und ja also ich habe
eigentlich mega bock drauf aber ich habe
es so beim einem kanal so den wunsch
deshalb so mega aufwendig zu machen und
möglichst spektakulär ich weiß jetzt
diese videos hier sind es auch
zu krass aber die davor und ich wollte
ja eigentlich dass es mehr in diese
richtung gehen aber ich habe halt echt
cool trat bock auf gaming ich habe auch
schon mit dem lehrer ein kleines gaming
projekt gestartet allerdings ist daraus
ist nichts geworden also wir haben ein
paar videos gedreht aber die dann wieder
eingestellt aber ich war auch schon hier
als letzten party video und das wird
schon sehr sehr geil darauf hätte ich
generell auf jeden fall schon bock markt
nicht vielleicht hätte ich auch einfach
mal trocken da einfach mal in die
praktische video hoch oder so wenn ich
was mache ich das auf jeden fall nicht
so aber das pulver
ich habe 40 prozent akku bei der tombola
aber das ist gar kein problem weil wenn
die kamera jetzt einfach ausgesehen kann
ich einfach wieder diesen coolen click
effect vom letzten mal drüber legen
brust die nächste frage lautet wie
findest du paul den cut davon wie ich
glaube dass so ein bisschen was getan
was kann er ein schneiden was du zum
beispiel nicht ganz ag aus löhne wohl
größte gehen zurück nach lüneburg liebe
bennett
da war er da gibt's effekt ich habe mich
jetzt noch nicht so im schnitt
auseinandergesetzt aber seine fotos zu
beruhigen was und ich glaube dass ich
mir auch mal wieder lust drauf hat eine
private name bisher schon geben also ich
find das echt mega cool hat ein super
korrekter typ und passt sehr gut rein so
jetzt geht es weiter mit den video für
morgen 12 uhr 30 das video für morgen
abend ist natürlich auch schon fertig
und für heute abend ist auch schon
fertig und das video für morgen mittag
kann ich 25 minuten früher beginnen als
geplant ich bin richtig produktiv was
auf jeden fall zu sagen dass das hier
nicht unbedingt mein alltag jeder spielt
weil ich noch mal ein gefühl mehr für
sie zu tun haben deswegen habe ich noch
gestern nach zwei videos für rime
geschnitten damit ich heute zeit hat
sich das video zu machen und natürlich
trotzdem noch zwei videos zu schneiden
über den tag verteilt und überhaupt auch
abends mit ihren weg zu gehen weil
logischerweise kann ich nicht jeden tag
gehen trainieren und wieder für mich
selbst machen so viel zeit habe ich
nochmal auf keinen fall und deswegen
sieht ein normaler arbeitstag bemerkt
ein bisschen interessanter aus und nicht
so langweilig wie heute wo ich relativ
wenig zu tun haben so jetzt geht's
weiter mit einem video mit felix was
morgen mittag kommt es sicherlich habe
jetzt komplett vergessen wo ich
aufgehört habe aber ich habe es
mittlerweile schon alles fertig hier
sieht jetzt auch schon dass es dunkel
ist und jetzt ist gerade den 21 uhr 30
hat also doch ein bisschen länger
gedauert alles als erwartet aber jetzt
kann ich endlich lehren abholen
ordentliche mal kurz follow me all
around here ist würde ich jetzt auch
hier überall gab es aber noch viel mehr
müll
hast du 2008 wegen irgendwelcher
spannenden reisen geplant
auch die duh die kamera mitnehmen ja und
zwar einerseits die fliege nach portugal
da werde ich auf jeden fall meine kamera
mitnehmen vielleicht habe ich musste und
sogar eine drohnen weiß vielleicht nehme
ich auch einmal wieder rede ist ohne mit
und verliert die dann wie ich sonst
immer das war ja in frankreich schon gut
und hat gut geklappt und ich bin in
norwegen glaube ich norwegen schweden
irgendwas skandinavisches ich weiß nicht
mehr genau
simbabwe und lernen ich war vielleicht
so eine fahrradtour irgendeine nordsee
vielleicht durch deutschland vielleicht
durch holland vielleicht durch
frankreich nämlich wird durch polen
würde über griechenland nach haben
apropos griechenland ja ich hatte
letztes jahr war ich auch hinkriegen und
habe davon noch super wie cool das
filmmaterial das muss natürlich auch
noch alles geschnitten werden wie heißt
das was wir benutzen das ist dass sie
juden crane v2 oder nur 21 wie lange
brauchst du im schnitt für ein baby
schnitt videoschnitt also zwischen einer
stunde aber eher zwischen anderthalb
stunden und 4
das variiert hat immer muss man sich ja
kraftakt war immer so easy innerhalb
einer stunde der stunde aber kraft
retten das thema ist hier wird auch in
freiheit gestellt vielleicht können wir
die mine blenden vielleicht können wir
das machen ich habe diese gab gefällt
viele fragen ja mal es ist so eine
beliebte frage wie lange dauert so eine
schnitt für so ein video wie dann
braucht man einfach im durchschnitt aber
es variiert immer total heftig aber im
homo katzen sind können dass eine bis
vier stunden auf jeden fall sein wie
hast du gewusst dass du selbstständig
sein
also das ist eine gute frage ich weiß es
war einfach so dieses dieses
freiheitsgefühl quasi einfach nicht
geschafft haben der sagt hey du musst
das und das machen sondern sich diese
dinge einzuteilen es war trotzdem immer
volle leistung zu geben und immer zu
arbeiten aber sie ist es halt einfach
selbst einteilen zu können und hat auch
wann und wo arbeiten zu können so der
traum ist dein handy es gerade keiner
kann weil da sind würdest du lieber eine
palme oder ein weihnachtsbaum sein
eine palme zum weihnachtsmann der wird
einfach nur ein jahr gebraucht und
benutzt sondern direkt entsorgt und da
hatte ich keinen bock drauf ein
weihnachtsmann wahrscheinlicher
weihnachtsbaum wie viel uhr bis dahin
ich meistens immer im ufo da die meist
von den anderen laden
ich bin um 9 das erscheint jetzt gar
nicht mal so früher bei erlernen sie
nochmal viel später da vielleicht ja
auch mal acht eine überlegung aber
später als neun will ich auf gar keinen
fall den hufen sein und die fahrt
richtung flughafen
ja aber auch schön was willst du später
beruflich machen das gleiche wie jetzt
ich will immer ähnlich videos schneiden
die das fällen videos drehen egal in
welchen plan egal für wen die sagen das
arbeitsumfeld entspannendes schneiden
guck mal köln kam rücken gestalten und
diese was war dein herz der gedanke als
du und das rufe zum ersten mal betreten
hast mach weiter so du bist ein cooler
tut mir leid ich bin mir da nicht so
sicher ich absolut auch nicht ja komm
nur sie muss aufpassen dass jetzt kein
betrunken zusammen fahren gibt das etwas
von denen das schon lange träumt warum
hast du nicht getan
vorwurfsvoll hier also ich würde gerne
bald tanken und fallschirmspringen und
gleichzeitig wird gehen wir zu einem
bungee seil von einem fallschirm also
mit einem fallschirm an diesem fall dran
mit der presse aufkommen weil aus dem
flugzeug und noch ganz viel reisen nach
asien und ich habe einfach keine zeit
für reisen
mach mal so eine art fan kann revue du
forderst 50 prozent mehr gehalt usw
vor der feier oder ok bekommst du nicht
magst du kanuten hat ja nein oder wohnst
du bei rewe
[Musik]
wo kommst du klar mit wem kann man
gewalt ja ich war glaube ich auch schon
gesehen hat was meinst du denn er weiß
wenn du angebote bekommen würdest zum
mond zu fliegen was würdest du mitnehmen
beziehungsweise welche person müsste es
überhaupt machen würde ich jetzt mein
bruder wenn ich nur jetzt machen könnte
und sonst nie wieder die chance bekäme
dann gericht tun würdest zum mond
fliegen wollen oder wie kraft
ich weiß nicht ob ich unter der ob ich
physisch ja physisch und psychisch zu
etablieren hat also müsst dafür
trainiert und war schon heftig aber es
gehört auch ein traum stelle bis zum
mond ja das stimmt schon aber du musst
evaluieren man ja immer nur immer also
die chance zu sterben ist eigentlich
schon relativ hoch dass das ding also
ich weiß nicht aber wer schließlich
würden egal ob die rakete außen genau
also muss ich musste sich persönlich
sagen weiß nicht ob es mir das wert wäre
mein leben so zu riskieren ich kann auch
nicht einfach sind wir sicher das ist
okay ist und sicheres autofahren
ja warst du früher gut in der schule
oder aus der stressbewältigung stress
gemacht zu dicker wird also ich war
nicht so ein krasser stress machen ich
habe der haut ich habe keinen geschlagen
oder so ein schrecklicher bei wurde
scheiß gemacht und halt späße und ich
witzig gemacht über andere leute und
lehrer abgefragt weil ich einmal
diskutieren ja so ein bisschen aber ja
man kann man könnte
hattest du wahrscheinlich mein sie oder
er als kind schon vor 1
was ihnen jetzt mal bzw
zu bekommen dann hat sich im glaubt zu
machen ja hab ich ja schon mal gesagt
das kind wollte ich immer maler werden
wegen den golf abdämpfen schneide man
muss keine ganzen arbeit ich habe
morgens oder hat sich komplett darauf
aufgearbeitet der so wie kann man nur so
dumm sein und das machen wollen
er übt mannschaft selbst also ja und
history ich glaube ich schon mal gesagt
ich habe irgendwann mit zwölf so
angefangen diese komischen videos im
internet gesehen und hab mir so geil wie
mache ich das hat die google und dann
hab ich ja spannende lebensgeschichte
und jetzt bin ich hier um zu verlieren
mann bringen
[Musik]
mit einer jubel
so habe da ist die preview
der nähe von stuttgart
[Musik]
so dass mit dem heutigen video ich bin
mega und ihr habt jetzt ungefähren
angerückt wie sonntag von mir aussieht
warten ein bisschen und strukturiert zum
ende hin und ich konnte euch leider auch
nicht bei allen begleiten aber ich bin
happy dass ich mal wieder geschafft
haben video hoch zu bringen wenn euch
das video gefallen hat oder wenn ihr
wollt habt nicht nur diese weise zu
begleiten dann guck mal wenn man anderen
videos dabei ab und nicht und guckt vor
allem auch bei diesem typen der kopf der
linken in der beschreibung bis dann
[Musik]